um so
um the script for a remote meeting and
then we'll move into the pledge
uh immediately after as chair of the
house labor industrial and
rehabilitative services committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
04 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically please note there is no
physical location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that we are
a providing public access to the meeting
by telephone
with additional access possible by video
or other electronic needs
we are utilizing zoom for this
electronic meeting all members of the
committee and select staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by clicking on the following
website address https colon
backslash backslash zoom dot us
backslash j backslash nine
seven one one five five seven
zero 70558 or
dialing one of the following phone
numbers one
three one two six two six
six seven nine nine or one
b providing public notice of the
necessary information for
accessing the meeting we previously gave
notice to the
public of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting
including how to access the meeting
using zoom or telephonically
this information is printed in the house
calendar
c providing a mechanism for the public
to alert the
public body during the meeting if there
are problems with the access
if anybody has a problem please call
271 3600
or email at hc
c s l e g dot state
dot nh dot u s
d during the meeting if the public is
unable to access the meeting
in the event that the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce staff that are on
the meeting assisting us
christina dyer is the meeting host
additional staff providing support are
jennifer four
and joel anderson actually i believe
that's
bradley green greenland
um at any rate this is a public meeting
of the house rehabilitative services
committee
um a copy of the agenda in minutes has
been posted in the main page of the
general court website
under the heading remote meetings please
note that all votes that are taken
during the meeting
shall be done by roll call vote let's
start the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during the
meeting
which is required under the right to
know law so let's do the roll call and
then we'll do the pledge
so um mr clerk roll call please real
quick question christina do i have to
yes please i'll write it down thank you
all right um representative
here i am at home and alone
representative representative broody he
had a court hearing that he
he's muted mr representative
[Music]
ben brodie you are muted okay i
am here and my secretary's working on
the other side of the room
thank you representative cahill
uh here in newmarket my wife is in the
house but not presently in the room
representative de sylvestro here
and i am alone
representative schmidt i am here
and i'm alone except for a bird which
you may see fly across
in front of me representative to me
i'm here and i'm alone
representative boardi here alone
representative bouchard i'm here at home
in home
myself i'm here in my bedroom in nashua
by myself
uh represent representative hall
cancer i'm here and my son is in the
room with me but he's asleep
uh i'm back and i'm alone i had some
technical difficulties
this rope between the cops broke
representative c worth i'm here
i'm in my home and i'm by myself
representative avaloni here at work
alone
representative o'day i'm here and alone
representative renzolo i am here
alone well actually i have my cap with
me
and representative nunes i'm here and
i'm alone in my residence
and chair i am here in my home office
alone
17 people present and three not here
thank you oh wait um i think
representative mackie could you uh
identify yourself and whether you're
you're muted thank you
yes this is representative and i am
representative flanagan what last chance
could you lead us in the pledge
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty
and justice
here today to uh address three bills
that were um
sent to interim study
the way we're going to do this is we're
going to take up
one bill at a time first in a work
session
where we'll discuss what we ought to do
with it and then we'll move
directly into an executive session for
that bill
we will um make make a motion and vote
and then we'll move on to a work session
for the second
and eventually the third bill there are
only two appropriate
motions to be made on interim study
one is to recommend that future
legislation be filed
and the other is that future legislation
should not be filed
so um any other motion is out of order
and um we can
proceed uh the first bill we're going to
take up in work session
is hb 738 that
bill is relative to protection from an
abusive work environment
i can provide a little bit of background
um
the the reason we sent this to uh
interim study
was because um uh there is an
interest on the part of the department
of administrative services
in developing a program that would
address civility in the workplace
um for
over a year they've been working on that
program
um they intended to have trainings for
um
managers and employees rolled out during
the winter
but just when they're getting ready to
do that
they're almost ready to do that and the
pandemic struck
so things are delayed i
understand that they have gone back to
work on
finalizing the trainings um
and um are getting ready to start the
trainings
later this fall um representative nunes
and i
have uh worked with the department and i
would welcome
representative nunes chiming in if he's
interested thank you mr chairman
um we did go through several meetings
with the
administrative group and many other
people from other departments
um that are in the state uh they all
uh joined in and developed a wonderful
program that they will be pushing out
uh as the chairman stated we did have
conversations
with uh the administration office over
um over the uh summertime
and as recently as in the past couple of
weeks and they have
um commissioner arlinghaus's group has
has committed to
completing this program and they would
like to get it pushed out
as soon as possible they've done a good
job and we'll also have access to go in
and look at that program to make
sure that it covered all the bases that
we talked with them about
um it was an honor to work with all of
these folks and you mr chairman in order
to get this
done as we both agreed uh
early on that this should have been
policy and not legislation
and uh and i believe that um that the
commissioners group
commissioner arlington house and his
group have worked very hard to to make
this possible so
a handclap to them because they did a
great job
and they continued on even when uh there
were no people in the offices they can
continue to work on the program so um
i'm i'm
very optimistic about the outcome of it
[Music]
all right um
i think what i'd like to do is uh i um
inform that uh
sorry um
the um i'm informed that
the prime sponsor of the bill um
representative schuett is listening in
and would like to say a few words and i
think before we get further
discussion um i'd ask uh the
uh host to um
do what she needs to do to let
representative she would
speak with us all right wonderful she's
in we'll just have her unmute and she
would be able to speak
representative schuett thank you very
much
i appreciate the opportunity to address
the committee mr chair um
i agree i also have been involved in
some of the meetings with
uh commissioner arlinghau and deputy
commissioner
and i believe that they are very earnest
in putting this forward as a policy
to all state employees and i'm pretty
satisfied with
package that they've developed and i
leave it to the committee as to
whether or not anything needs to go
forward continue to monitor this
a couple of the comments that i would
make is that both the representative
nunes and myself have asked to be kept
in the loop and
given access to the training uh once it
is uh
online so that we can experience it
along with the
managers and the state employees um
committee
this is manny um i guess how
um i should raise my hand but i just
wanted to say that i think just
continuing the monitoring of this
um is a great idea and i'm
happy to see that the department of
administrative services is taking it
seriously and it's implementing
trainings
i will say that i've got the
participants box open on the side of my
screen so as hands go up i will respond
are we satisfied and ready to move into
executive sessions
representative sorry i was agreeing with
you
okay all right thank you uh
representative uh your hand is up
yeah i just think uh for the
subcommittee work session do we need a
motion and uh our second or should we
just
i believe that uh we don't need a motion
in a work session the motion comes in
the executive session
i'm correct on that right christina um
i've seen it done both ways
um i know the paperwork looks like it's
a subcommittee um
so not necessary as i said i've seen it
both
both ways so we could move right into
executive session i see no need to vote
twice
um mr chairman as as chairman i believe
you have the right to
call the meeting into executive session
yep that's what i'm about to do we're
moving into executive session
on hb 738
and at this point it would be
appropriate for to have a motion
um representative nunes do you have a
motion
thank you mr chairman yes i do i'd like
to recommend that no further legislation
is needed on this item
i'll second it mr jim thank you
representative flanagan
rudy
representative baruti he has probably
stepped away
yes yes representative cahill
yes representative de silvestro
yes representative schmidt
yes representative to me
yes representative boardy yes
representative bouchard yes
myself yes representative hall
representative kansler yes
representative flanagan yes
representative seaworth yes
representative avalani yes
representative o'day yes
representative renzolo yes
representative callum
representative mackey yes
representative nunez yes
and chairman yes
vote is 17-3
okay i'm gonna unmute myself again
so i would move us along to a work
session
on house bill 1386
this is relative to employment
protection for qualified patients
of new hampshire's therapeutic cannabis
program
again some background on this one
representative thomas was a prime
sponsor
um and testified before the committee as
and she also participated in a
subcommittee work session that we um had
on this bill
and um the
there was not i
don't want to put thoughts into people's
minds but uh
the um there were some issues raised
both during the hearing and during the
subcommittee
um as to how the bill would be
implemented
um i don't recall any testimony
testimony saying that
people who are using therapeutic
cannabis
ought to be fired just for that there
were concerns
perhaps impaired um
working certain types of jobs and uh
in the end i believe the conclusion was
that there were no easy solutions
those concerns and
i also called representative thomas uh
in recent days
and uh she remains interested in working
on
um uh on the issue and
file legislation going forward possibly
a study committee
but with that i would open it up to
mr chairman yes representative flanagan
um i happen to concur i think uh
by legalizing uh medical marijuana uh
there has probably got to be some
guidelines and i'm so glad that you
mentioned that it would be a study
committee because
this bill right now i believe we've had
parameters in it that need to do further
research so
i'd be i'd be supportive of a bill
dealing with a study committee of
specifics and as you said is you know
you you can't have positions
or occupations in which the public is is
being served and someone being on
cannabis so
i'd be supportive somewhat supportive of
where you are right now
representative i would uh
thank you mr chairman i would i tend to
agree with representative flanagan
i was uh in this uh work committee the
study group that uh when they came in to
talk to us about
about the thing and the issue that i had
through this was
that i did not like mandating to private
industry what they should do and what
they shouldn't do
uh but as we move towards legalization
in the state and at some point it will
happen
i believe that uh when that does happen
that uh things will need to be in place
in order to
uh suffice this need so i am
in agreement with mr flanagan
[Music]
thank you mr chairman um will workmen's
comp and liability insurance be
at the table for the study committee
um i don't know that i'm in a position
to uh
to say but i would agree that it's a
good idea
thank you mr chairman
seeing no other hands are we ready to
let's do that um
the um uh
moving into executive session on house
bill 1386
i usually have this prepared ahead of
time representative flanagan would you
like to make a motion
i do but i'm somewhat hesitant mr
chairman because
um can we recommend further legislation
but qualify it by saying in the form of
a study
okay let's go move okay do we have a
second
second i'm not sure where that came from
but representative soucy seconds um
mr chairman could i uh interject just
one one moment
of course i think representative avalani
brings up a good point so if i can amend
my motion
to include a commit subcommittee with
concerns about workers compensation and
liability too
mr soucy do you uh maintain your second
i do
thank you no mr clerk
hb 1386 representative susie
representative cahill yes representative
sylvestrom yes representative schmidt
yes representative to me yes
representative boardy yes representative
bouchard yes
myself yes representative hall
representative kinsler yes
representative flanagan yes
representative seaworth yes
representative avalon yes
representative o'day yes representative
renzo
yes representative callum
representative mackey yes
representative newness yes
uh and chair yes
i like unanimous votes um
okay now we're moving on to a work
session on
house bill 1576 this is relative to
establishing a targeted workforce
on development program again i'll try to
when this came to the committee in a
hearing
earlier this year most of the testimony
came from
the policy
advisor i think to the governor
mr elms i believe is his name and um
we were told that um while this bill had
supported a valuable concept um
uh he wasn't really ready ready for
prime time
we were also told that there would be
another bill coming from the senate that
would be better
um structured um
obviously that never happened for us um
qualified as not ready to go forward
so with that um and there was also some
testimony
against the bill from um the um
uh i believe it was the uh
june uh colleges because there is
the the bill was shifting money from
scholarships to
um debt relief
so um at any rate that's well that's
what we've got
um and nothing has happened in the
interim um
so um with that i'd open it up to uh
discussion
mr chairman yes mr representative
flanagan
uh in light of the fact of the the
brevity of the testimony
and obviously the governor's office to
resubmit it
um i think we should just let this one
go
i tend to agree with the ranking member
seeing no hands seeing no one jumping up
and down on the screen
um i would appear that we were ready to
move to executive session on this
any objection seeing none
we are going into executive session on
house bill 1576.
do we have a motion uh representative
flanagan
yeah uh mr chairman i recommend no
further action
do we have a second i'll second that mr
chairman
thank you uh representative soucy um
all right uh representative susie
yes representative rudy
representative hill yes representative
yes representative schmidt yes
representative yes representative boardy
yes blue chart yes
yes representative hall representative
kinsler
yes representative flanagan
yes representative seaworth
yes representative of illani
yes representative o'day yes
representative renzolo yep
yes representative nunes
yes and chair yes
thank you folks um
mr clerk you can send the paperwork to
um
our researcher christine dyer
uh what's what's the best way christina
for him to get that to you
actually um i would say for any of that
uh paperwork you can go ahead and send
that
probably to the clerk i'm sure he's he
would be
expecting it um but anyone that made a
motion we do
need a the recommendation report um you
can send those to me and then we'll get
okay so um our our motions came from
i believe representative flanagan on two
and representative nunes on one um
and i would uh in fact i would suggest
that you send those to me first because
i'm supposed to review them
so if you could email those reports to
me today
um i would recommend that you keep them
quite brief
um and um no need to put a lot of uh
sweat and tears into it um but uh
mr mr chairman yes yes sir um
so basically send you an email and copy
uh christina in is that what you want
you either you can just send it directly
to me and i'll forward it to her or you
can copy her on it as well that that
that would be fine and then all i would
have to do is just give it a thumbs up
to go ahead and
move down the pipeline and just so i
know what
the the bill numbers were um that we're
dealing with today
the bill numbers that you are dealing
with are hp 1386
and hb 1576
hang on i need to find a crayon 13 what
1386.
and what was the other one 1576
1576 and none of these pens right
um okay if if there's any issues you can
give me a call or send me a message if
you do that or go back to the original
email i think
okay here we go
mr chairman confirming uh i'm hb 738
correct
that's correct thank you so much
thank you um and
as we're drawing to a close here i i
would
i guess i'd like to say that over the
last two years um
i've thoroughly enjoyed working with the
entire committee um
and uh i've enjoyed developing the
relationships with uh
with all of you and um
as the as we bring it to a close um
i'd like to save i consider you all
friends
um and we don't agree on everything
we've certainly had uh some um
energetic discussions but uh um i think
we've been
generally uh respectful of each other
i've tried to
lead the committee with respect and uh
you know thank you all for um
for making a fun committee to work with
so um
with that uh i guess we have a moment
for other comments if anybody wants to
make one
well thank you mr chairman this is andy
renzullo
you it's been good good working with you
and i must commend you
on your as your in your final final
committee uh
meeting you've you got the republicans
to do all the work
and mr chairman it's been an honor and
privilege to work with all of you
uh as you know i'm not coming back um we
don't necessarily agree on everything
but we're certainly not disagreeable and
i agree with you 100 percent
the professionalism um of people is
is a quality that i think is uni
somewhat unique to this this committee
it's uh
it can be difficult at times and trying
but we deal with some unique positions
and policy issues
that i think no other committee deal
with whether it's unemployment workers
compensation
it can be somewhat complicated to the
average member so
i'd like to concur with the chairman i
i'm very appreciative of all the work
that everybody on this committee has
done
um the respect we've had for one another
and jack
i've known you for quite a while i wish
you the best of luck uh
we're gonna always agree but at least we
could have conversation so thanks again
and good luck to everybody
thank you mr chairman i like to echo the
representative soucy's and flanagan's
words this committee has always been a
pleasure to work with
we bring a multifaceted knowledge to the
table
to work on behalf of the hampshire and i
just want to thank you again for not
bringing in the outside
vitriol of other committees and things
like that
this committee has always been above
that and i want to thank you for that
now we've got an election coming up um
many of us are running
um some of us will be re-elected and
and some will uh perhaps request to be a
part of the labor committee
none of us know how many of those
requests will be
um honored um i have no idea if uh
i will be chair if i'm reelected but uh
if i am and if i see
many or most of you next year um that
would be delightful
um with that um thank you for your
um three unanimous votes today and
um looking forward to uh seeing you all
with that we're gonna
thank you mr chairman and the rest of